[Musique]
bonjour julia kristeva bonjour et merci
de nous accorder ce grand entretien
durant lequel on va explorer l'identité
européenne est votre définition de
l'identité européenne alors vous êtes
philosophe écrivain vous êtes
psychanalyste et quand vous décrivez
votre identité vous citer ceux ci de
nationalité française d'origine bulgare
citoyenne européenne
d'adoption américaine une identité très
complète donc vous êtes vraiment une
fanatique de l'europe un gilet kristeva
je pense qu'on peut utiliser ce mot vous
dit tout mon histoire va dans ce sens
quand vous évoquez évidemment la
bulgarie totalitaire de votre jeunesse
la bulgarie vous avez vécu 24 ans avant
de vous exiler derrière le rideau de fer
vous rêviez d'europe c'est là que se
trouve finalement le fondement de votre
identité c'est dans ce rêve là qui était
le vôtre gamine
oui dans l'apprentissage du français
bien sûr qui m'a conduite à cette vision
universaliste et et diversifiée qu'est
le rêve européen
très soutenue dans dans ses démarches
par ma mère qui était scientifique mais
qui s'était consacré à ses filles et
qu'ils ne soutenaient pas ma guerre avec
mon père qui était très croyant et
néanmoins
extrêmement tourner vers les lettres et
qui nous disait qu' il faut absolument
sortir de cet instinct de l'enfer c'est
ainsi qu'il désignait les pays de l'est
comme on dit maintenant les succursales
du soviétisme et qui nous faisait
apprendre à ma soeur et moi le français
l'anglais l'allemand pour ma soeur moi
je lui parle beaucoup moins bien et j'ai
découvert récemment mes cahiers de l'us
lycées et de l'universitaire
je recopiais des poèmes de 2
date de la fontaine des phrases de
monter ce que petit à petit cette idée
française de l'europe ces gros
cristalliser à moi vous aviez cet âge là
on vous voilà sur la photo c'était la
culture européenne qui vous fascine et
alors c'est je vous ai confié cette
image parce que c'est un moment et c'est
une image que j'emporte de la bulgarie
j'ai vécu beaucoup plus longtemps en
france maintenant que j'ai vécu en
bulgarie et j'ai l'honneur de d'être
porteuse de la culture française à
l'étranger dans les universités
américaines
on me considère comme comme une
représentante de la république française
et j'en suis fier mais j'en porte de
bulgarie justement c'est cette image
d'une fête qui n'existe nulle part
ailleurs qui est le fait de l'alphabet
de l'alphabet slave qui était inventée
par deux frères byzantin cyrille et
méthode et qui pour qu'on puisse
christianisé les slaves il devait avoir
une écriture donc ils ont inventé
l'alphabet slave et le jour du 24 mai
qu'est le jour de ses deux seins les
premiers élèves la gêne ruban kenny que
je suis premier élève portait aussi des
lettres de l'alphabet en incarner une
lettre de l'alphabet et on se rangeait
de manière à faire un nom propre d'un
grand écrivain ou une phrase ou un poème
est donc pour moi la bulgarie était déjà
une néo réalité culturelle quelque chose
qui se construit à travers le langage et
l'écriture est une fois cette idée de la
nation comprise comme une création
culturelle est en traduite en français
j'étais prête à épouser le rêve européen
alors votre identité elle se définit
aussi avec le voyage qui a suivi cette
période bulgare vous aimez cité
saint-augustin j'ai lu quelques articles
où ça revient souvent vous dites je n'ai
qu'une seule patrie finalement c'est le
voyage plus que la bulgarie ou la france
votre patrie c'est le voyage c'est le
nomadisme d'une certaine manière mais
écoutez je suis contente que vous
parliez de cela parce que j'ai écrit
un livre sur mon histoire sous forme
d'entretiens avec un jeune psychologue
écrivain et journaliste samuel doc qui
s'appelle je me voyage j'ai voulu faire
d'entorse au français en écrivant cette
phrase ou si le souligner donc je viens
de loi aussi mais pour insister sur
cette transe forme mobile it et
ce mouvement qui constitue ma conception
de l'identité et je pense que c'est un
trait distinctif de la culture
européenne
ce qui est qui est quelque chose
d'extrêmement complexe c'est je pense le
trésor que nous portons à l'humanité je
suis
peut-être un peu présomptueuse de dire
cela est important c'est ce trésor et en
les cultivant ma façon mais je pense que
c'est par la culture européenne que nous
avons peut-être la possibilité de
refonder l'europe économique politique
militaire pour qu'elle soit à la fois
plus unie et plus attentive aux
diversités et bien cette culture
européenne elle se constitue elle se
construit par deux volets d'une part les
la richesse des cultures nationales et
j'essaie de vous dire combien la culture
bulgare qu'on connaît peu en france est
originale et riche et combien ces
cultures nationales peuvent être blessés
et prouvé des dépressions nationale
comme un patient on peut être les
déprimés combien on essaye de les sortir
de là en les poussant vers le
nationalisme
qui est un antidépresseur mais qui peut
tourner mal en crainte de grands
emplacements colère etc et combien en
même temps ces différentes cultures
nationales à travers le temps à travers
deux millénaires au moins se sont
appuyés sur un fond culturel
qui leur a permis d'établir des
passerelles entre elle et ce front
culturel et on reviendra à mon voyage ce
front culturel est constituée par par le
miracle grec
par le christianisme son substrat juifs
sa greffe musulmane dans lesquelles nous
trouvons des réponses pas vraiment mais
d'ouverture de questions et des
questions qui sont essentielles
aujourd'hui dans un monde qui se
fracturent il est condamné à la en
vérité tu sais qui sont les questions de
l'identité de la liberté de la religion
de sécularisation est ce que vous dites
c'est que pour que le projet européen
fonctionne il ne faut pas que les
identités nationales se dilue il faut
pas qu'elle se dilue d'une part il faut
qu on les cultive qu'on les comprenne
mieux et qu'on essaye de les opposer à
la banalisation de la connexion aux ide
english globish c'est la seule façon des
cultures nationales peuvent faire
contrepoids à cela mais il faut aussi
créer des passerelles entre elle et ses
passerelles sont fait parce ce fonds
traditionnels des cultures qui nous
précèdent et des religions qui nous
précèdent et d'un événement unique au
monde qui s'est produite en europe et
nulle part ailleurs qui est qu'on a
rompu le fil avec la tradition mais
rompre le fil avec la tradition ne veut
pas dire faire un mécanisme matériel est
ce qu'il est mais connaît il faut les
reprendre les réévaluer et les rénover
il est grand ce prix là le voyage et la
définition que nous trouvons dans
l'histoire grecque ou judéo chrétienne
est la phrase qui vous a impressionné
dans je vous remercie de votre lecture
dans mon itinéraire à savoir que je me
voyage et que le voyage est mon identité
est un effet quelque chose qu'on trouve
chez saint-augustin qui dit une seule
patrie le voyage je suis devenu question
moi même et cette identité qui n'est pas
verrouillé qui n'est pas cristallisées
qui n'est pas revendicatif mais qui se
transforment et qui bouge et bien c'est
un des trésors que nous lègue cette
culture européenne
transversale aux identités l'homo
européenne ue s'il existe julia kristeva
aujourd'hui moi j'ai le courage de dire
qu'il existe et blade prétention
peut-être il existe femmes comprises
évidemment et qui est justement
créé par cette multiplicité nationale et
par cette universalité interrogative par
exemple la liberté qui est que nous
lègue se se font gréco judéo chrétien la
liberté n'est pas envoyer des bombes
casser le passé détruire celui qui n'est
pas comme nous on voit ça très bien
ressurgir du fonds de l'héritage russe
qui est beaucoup plus complexe que cela
mais mais qui nous blessent aujourd'hui
la vérité selon quand ces lotos
commencement la philosophe que je suis
aussi mais aussi la psychanalyste qui
vous parle consiste à s'adresser aux
déprimé à lui dire votre plainte votre
colère on peut les réinventer vous êtes
libre non pas quand vous cassez et vous
casser mais quand vous faites une
initiative quand vous prenez la parole
quand vous devenez singulier quand vous
vous posez des questions quand vous
ouvrez de nouvelles questions quand vous
posez des questions voilà ses 7,7 cette
conception de la liberté comme hôte au
commencement questionnement
recommencement transforme habilité et
quelque chose je crois que qui est
peut-être pas unique au monde ça existe
dans les marches de différentes
religions mais qui s'est constitué comme
comme valeur mouly tic sociale et
partageables entre les sexes c'est la
tradition platonicienne aussi dû
dialogue continuel dialogue continuel en
effet de anin de platon qui ne donne pas
de synthèse mais qui désagrège et couvre
de nouveau des questions ou la filière
politique et d'aristote il y à un espace
politique ça c'est la grande question
d'aujourd'hui qui se divise en france
entre un bloc maintenant et pas
seulement deux mais comment faire un
bloc politique tout en le singularise
ans c'est à dire que chacun avec sa
biographie enrichi ce bloc de manière
singulière soyez vous mêmes et notre
bloc pourra respirer ça c'est aussi une
vision
spécifiquement vous la trouvez pas en
chine vous la trouvez même pas en russie
vous la trouvez en russie dans la grande
littérature mais pas dans l'espace
politique que nous avons maintenant
c'est c'est le fond des droits de
l'homme les droits de l'homme s'est
conjugué au singulier et ça recommence
depuis la tradition je vous dit
d'ailleurs l'europe se définit par un
point d'interrogation en europe
l'identité ce n'est pas en culte mais
une interrogation oui
je renvoie à nietzsche qui disait que on
a mis un grand point sur le plus grand
sérieux dieu le point d'interrogation et
je transforme ça en disant partout
aujourd'hui dans le monde on revendique
l'identité en et chinois ont ni
jihadistes ont ni femme on est gay une
étrange armes on veut une identité de
l'identité est culte bien sûr s'il n'y a
pas d'identité on sombre dans la
dépression il faut désirons d'identité
ce sont des antidépresseurs mais pour
qu'il se durcissent pas qu'elle ceux qui
se disent pas en guerre fratricide il
faudrait d ouvrir aux questions faut
qu'elles soient mauvais entretien des
fois que ce soit vivante et qu'elle se
pose en question elle même et je dis que
l'espace européen ça se peut être une
des définitions de l'espace européen
s'est transformé le culte en un amour
pour les points d'interrogation vous
vous parler de religion
quel est le lien justement entre
l'identité européenne et la religion
quelle place on les racines chrétiennes
dans le projet européen tel que vous le
voyez aujourd'hui moi je pense d'abord
que les racines chrétiennes sont
évidemment
numériquement importante dans l'état
actuel des populations mais c'est une
fleur dans le bouquet gréco judéo
chrétien et la dérive musulmane mais et
je reprends ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure c'est le seul point géographique
le seul endroit au monde on a rompu le
fil avec la tradition c'est la
sécularisation et c'est un des grands
une norme des grandes questions qui
spécifie les la fragmentation
de l'ordre
globalisé aujourd'hui la difficulté de
le vivre en europe on a rompu son fils
hannah arendt était une grande des
grandes
philosophes qui ont pointé cela mais le
travail a commencé avec la renaissance
avec les lumières françaises ne signifie
pas qu on abolit les religions comme
certains le pensent il s'agit de
transformer les religieux un objet de
connaissance la foi est un
investissement de la vie de l'autre et
de l'altérité de quelque chose qui nous
dépasse et que nous sommes aussi mais
c'est aussi un objet de connaissance et
l'étudié le faire connaître aux
étudiants aux élèves aux petits enfants
aussi est un projet européen que nous
n'avons pas suffisamment développée et
ceci fera partie sans doute aussi de ce
qui nous reste à faire quand on veut
refonder l'europe comment apprendre les
fondements y compris religieux de nos
valeurs
l'intellectuel que vous êtes a une
vision très claire de l'europe dans la
tête est ce que l'europe vous l'avez
aussi dans le ventre jeux léa kristeva
oui par exemple j'ai appris mon fils
david des poèmes qui me viennent
justement de mon enfance en bulgarie par
passant par la france l'angleterre et et
la poésie et nous récitons ensemble
par exemple la fontaine la diversité
c'est ma devise ou j'aime
le jeu l'amour les livres la musique la
ville et la campagne
enfin tout il n'est rien qui est de me
soir souverain bien jusqu'au sombre
plaisir d'un choeur mélancolique ça
c'est la diversité de l'europe mais dit
en français avec
presque une sorte d'hymne à la joie
alors parlons de cette identité
plurielle vous aimez l'astrophysique si
je ne m'abuse et vous dites les
astrophysiciens aujourd'hui parlent plus
d'univers mais de multivers et nous
aussi finalement nous sommes tous des
des multivers et l'europe en soi est un
multi vert je trouve que c'est une
définition très intéressante pour
comprendre votre votre vision de
l'europe merci d'avoir
prospecter vont travailler jusque là ma
mère
m'avait beaucoup encouragée dans dans
mes ambitions d'être astrophysicienne
mais mes parents n'étant en ayant pas
été communiste je pouvais pas suivre
cette voie et je me suis tourné vers le
multivers non pas astrophysique mais le
multivers du microcosme est en danger
j'ai choisi une professeure et une
profession
deux soignantes parce que je dis que ma
profession et deux soignantes de parce
que je soigne la vie psychique de
psychanalyste je redécouvre ce multi
vers cette pluralité de deux facettes
qui constitue chaque être humain et qui
sont souvent refoulés clivé
meurtri traumatisée et qui créent des
symptômes dans ces cas là et le travail
analytique dans le transfert c'est à
dire un amour partagé
permet à la personne de reconstruire ses
multi vers et à partir de là de créer de
multiples liens avec les autres à mon
niveau j'essaie de ça fait quelques
années déjà que je fais cette
proposition vous savez qu'il ya beaucoup
de bureaucratie il reprend les les
propositions les met dans un tiroir et
ça me donne rien mais peut-être bien ce
nom on entendra cela
je crois que ce serait intéressant de
créer un forum des cultures européennes
ou peut-être avec
un conseil qui définirait les étages de
ce forum mais qui se pencherait à la
fois sur les diverses nationalités
parce que comme disait gerudo les
nations aux moeurs d'imperceptibles
politesse et souvent pas seulement des
impolitesses mais des dénis arrogant des
cultures nationales les conduisent à des
dépressions et après à des nationalismes
et bien de valoriser les cultures
nationales et de l'est les fructifier de
leur fronde et et aussi de chercher ces
passerelles commune en se penchant sur
la mémoire traditionnel la grèce le
judaïsme le christianisme
je répète cela parce que beaucoup de
personnes comme moi qui est ce la
terrisse comme athée oublie de manière
parfois inconsciente parfois
politiquement correct ses dimensions et
c'est extrêmement important de 2,2
transvaal hué dû réévaluer ses et
héritage quel est le bulletin de santé
de l'europe aujourd'hui vous qui êtes
soignante vous dirais qu'elle est dans
quel état cette europe aujourd'hui moi
je suis très attentive aux critiques
amères que beaucoup de mes amis
formule par rapport à l'europe et leur
leur diagnostic que je contresigne c'est
que l'europe et les chaos
parce que même s'il y a un rebond
maintenant face aux problèmes de
l'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie
même si on a trouvé un nouveau souffle
pour créer une défense européenne et ses
termes d'unités les fissures
apparaissent très vite les souverainisme
se
présenter et casse déjà le consensus et
les sanctions prendront de l'effet très
tard donc l'europe
galante mais sans l'europe et sans cet
esprit multivers orientée vers les
profondeurs des cultures trans valu en
mobilisant les gens dans ce trésor qui
les constituent il n'y a plus la
fragmentation de leur globalité court
vers le chaos ça reste aujourd'hui
l'europe le meilleur rempart contre les
totalitarismes
moi j'en suis persuadé et je suis à
chaque fois rassuré dans mon optimisme
et que ce n'est pas un en fait je suis
pessimiste énergique pas vraiment une
une optimiste qui attend que ça vient de
l'extérieur j'essaie de travailler la
place je suis pour que ceux ci se
produisent mais cette conception
européenne et du lien social et de la
personne et le seul antidote à ce qui
nous vient des contradictions et des
conflits qui sont en train de se former
un peu partout autour de nous j'ai un
petit questionnaire à vous soumettre
julia kristeva si l'europe était un
paysage quel serait ce paysage
moi j'étais ébloui par les crocs paul et
le parti non un mariage du du ciel de la
terre
de l'eau pas très loin avec l'élégance
des colonnades et le parthénon d'athéna
la ds femmes de la sagesse je pense que
c'est un symbole de l'harmonie
et avec une place dès le début attribuée
à la pensée au féminin
si l'europe était une personnalité ce
serait aussi une femme qui avait vous
choisi moi j'ai choisi mozart parce que
on mais je n'oublie pas les femmes
mozart est quelqu'un qui est pour moi
composent il il rit en composant il
écrit en composant il joue en composants
et là on trouve le multivers est
l'exemple le plus frappant de cette
petite composition
c'est qu'il a mise en scène la mort
la comédie hétérosexuels
dans don giovanni
et il dénonce évidemment la bu par
le grand
féodal
donjon grand homme libertat s'étend à
toutes les femmes il est évidemment
critique mais de manière très différente
demi tour parce que quand
nous dénonçons aujourd'hui
la maltraitance des femmes on risque de
dénier ou de deux d'oublier
le désir alors que tout en dénonçant il
sait faire rire le désir et ça c'est
aussi un très
européen alors si l'europe était en mai
al c'est le champagne
sens tellement évident ça vous semble
tellement évident le sommet la journée
mais oui mais parce que je si si on
reprend notre idée de multivers de cette
culture multiple de fêtes de d'ouvrir
des questions on arrive à la poésie et
je ne résiste pas à la tentation de vous
citer baudelaire ou lesquelles la poésie
c'est quoi c'est la vaporisation et la
centralisation du mois si vous arrivez à
vous vaporisez
vous planez et vous êtes dans un bonheur
c'est la société d extravagant ça aussi
c'est un legs européen et le champagne
va avec la vaporisation
alors si l'europe était un tableau julia
kristeva ah oui là c'est beaucoup plus
idéologique on retombe sur les valeurs
de la république c'est la liberté
guidant le peuple c'est le tableau de
delacroix et qu'on voit la voilà il ya
toujours le féminin il y a le gavroche
l'enfant parce que c'est un des poèmes
que j'ai apprise au sida à david sur une
barre à 4 milliards de pvc victor hugo
la mort stupide durante et l'officier
fit grace donc
voilà l'esprit révolutionnaire français
c'est
c'est quelque chose qui manque à la à
l'europe marchande si le raf était un
hymne
qu'il fallait parce qu'il y en a déjà un
double le délai joie si on le changer
mais moi je ne suis pas très partante je
les aime beaucoup parce que je trouve
comme on m'avait posé les questions les
questions en préparant notre rencontre
je me suis demandé qu'est ce qu'on peut
proposer à la place et je trouvais que
c'était
je ne trouvais pas d'autre solution
celui là est très bien expliqué nous
pourquoi pour moi pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que il y a à la base de
deux sets ce mouvement de la neuvième
symphonie de beethoven il y à l'eau de
la joie de schiller qui chante justement
le paradis
de l'amour et du bonheur de la joie que
les êtres humains peuvent trouver
ensemble dans la paix cenjp hymne à la
paix dans ces temps de guerre il ne faut
pas l'oublier même si ça reste toujours
nous visons et l'autre raison c'est que
mon dernier travail et concept créé
était consacrée maintenant il donné lieu
à un livre sur dostoïevski
qui s'appelle face à la mort ou le sexe
santé du langage est un des personnages
de surf ski mitia karamazov ou qui est
le parricide qui est un homme qui pense
que la beauté peut sauver le monde mais
c'est pas n'importe quelle beauté ça
commence par madone la madone et ça se
termine en ce dom c'est une beauté
tragique et en tension permanente et
bien lui pour exprimer sa façon de voir
la beauté il sert et site l'hymne à la
joie de chelers donc il a inventé en
quelque sorte l'hymne européen c'est le
prototype
2 l'hymne européen et de l'europe que
nous trouvons chez dostoïevski
merci beaucoup julia kristeva évidemment
comme générique de fin quoi de mieux que
cette ode à la joie c'est hymne à la
joie que l'on réécoute merci de nous
avoir accordé ce temps merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]